thank you
what they were doing right now
[Music]
give me
a year ago to the day
we were sitting in a conference room in
Miami and I asked you what you thought
you guys needed to get over the
threshold and you said in part
you knew you could get it done
why was that belief
in that moment so strong and what does
it feel like to be right
I just know why Coach Pat and Coach
spoke wanted me to be here and that's to
compete at a high level one to win
championships
I know that the group that they put
around me at all times is going to give
me an opportunity to do so so I was
always very very confident in that I
worked extremely hard with the team with
Brickley I can score on Remy all day
every day as I've posted on Instagram so
I'm just confident I know the work that
we all put into it so I know what we're
capable of but nobody's satisfied we
haven't done anything we don't play just
to win the Eastern Conference we played
it when the whole thing
have you been uh taken aback by some of
the shots that Caleb Martin has made we
know he's he obviously as a tough
competitor has come a long way but some
of the shots he was hitting tonight and
maybe even earlier in the series did any
of them like surprise you at all no that
might have surprised you all to the
untrained eye he just looks like he's an
undrafted guy who's been in the G League
who's
um started in what Charlotte and now
he's here started on two-way contract to
y'all that's what it looks like to us
he's a hell of a player a hell of a
Defender playmaker shot maker all of the
above
everybody's seeing Caleb work on those
shots day in and day out so it doesn't
surprise us we've seen it every single
day and I'm so proud and happy for him
and he's going to even be even better in
his next round and I don't think he's
going to be the surprise to anybody else
any longer
uh Jimmy SPO was just talking about
Caleb saying that he has the respect of
you guys being a competitor how has he
earned that aside from what he's done on
the floor for you
I think that everybody sees what he's
doing in the games
but the real work is done when he's in
the gym by himself with his trainer
all the countless amounts of reps to
prepare him for this moment he doesn't
shy away from it like so many guys on
our roster they never shy away from the
big moment we love them for that we want
them continue to be that and he's been
huge for us he really has been he's kept
us in the game he's won us some games on
both sides of the floor
I mean if he ain't Soldier now he's
going to be in this league for a long
time
Caleb is part of this but this is the
third game in the series where you got
shot 50 from three
what can you say about not I mean
obviously he made some threes too but
the other guys in the team stepping up
and just
with Incredible shot making throughout
the series
yeah you want some free boy stuff over
here man
um
we just you know we stay with it we
stayed of course shoot the opening shots
stay confident even when they're not
going in you got to take them you got to
take the right ones everyone that
everybody takes
everybody thinks it's going in and then
if you get that same shot the next
possession down you got to take it again
because we all think it's going in
everybody's confidence so high we gotta
believe that we can do something
incredibly special
so we're gonna hit the ground running
when we get to Denver
and uh I like our chances
Jimmy I want to ask about something
that's been talked about with the heat
for literally decades but you guys came
in as an eight seed and you survived
losing three in a row and all the
history that was coming down at you how
does that apply to heat culture what
you've been able to accomplish this
particular spring I'm not going to say
losing three in a row is part of the
heat culture that we like to talk about
we don't play to lose we don't want to
lose their incredible team over there
and it will be for a while
I just think you know the guys that
coach Beau and Coach Pat put together
when a guy goes down the next guy could
fill in that Gap and do exactly what
that guy that went down did
um and do it at a high level
and then you know be humble enough to
know that when that guy comes back you
got to take a step back and get back in
your role and nobody ever complains they
always do exactly what you ask of them
to do which is why you want to play with
guys like that which is why they're the
reason that we win so many games I don't
call them role players I call them
teammates because
Your Role can change any given day
especially with how many games I've
missed and you know in and out of lineup
off nights whatever you call it
um but we we got some Hoovers we got
some real deal basketball players that
can score can defend can pass
um and can win games for us
you know in order to win a title and in
the next round you're going to have to
get everybody to raise their game up
especially on the defensive end but
specific to jokic what do you think the
key will be to slowing him down in this
series
I don't know I got two days to figure
that out we have two days to figure that
out
um before game one oh my God y'all saw
that
goddamn bumblebee
um
so we we will lock in on them but you
know I think we get to enjoy this till
midnight which is right around the
corner and then it's time to lock in on
the Nugget so I'll be able to answer
that for you when I talk to you on
Wednesday I think